à
comme on se retrouve youtube tu m'as ça
m'a un peu manquée mais pas tant que ça
genre là il est deux heures du mat par
exemple vous allez voir cette vidéo dans
un peu moins de 20 heures ça ça va pas
manquer par exemple faire tout le set up
l'elite les machins et cetera ça m'a pas
manqué non plus mais écrire un truc et
vous le dire vous dire ce que je pense
et cetera de quelque chose et avoir
votre avis votre retour en commentaire
et compagnie ça ça a manqué d'une
manière générale vous ou même manquer
l'interaction que j'ai avec vous
j'espère vous avez passé de bonnes
vacances et oui c'est vrai y avait un
peu de laisser-aller oui voilà moi
j'aime bien je me la non peut se
concentrer quand même sur la vidéo au
bas si vous insistez non non mais si
abbassi je vais l'enlever moi j'ai envie
qu'on se concentre sur cette vidéo
revient
voir il ya quelques années comme
beaucoup de créateurs et de créatrices
j'ai ouvert un compte tipi qui pis est
une plateforme qui permet de donner de
l'argent aux créateurs et aux créatrices
directement deux manières soit mensuels
soit ponctuelle donc l'idée c'est un
petit peu de sortir ou dans tout cas
d'avoir une autre source de revenus que
la publicité sur youtube et c'était
différent des craintes funding
habituelles type lui les compagnies
parce que c'était pas pour un projet
forcément c'était juste pour nous aider
au quotidien en fait et d'ailleurs ont
poussé le plus possible les tips mensuel
donc type ça vient de pourboire et
d'ailleurs ont poussé le plus possible
les types mensuel du coup il ya eu des
créateurs qui ont chopé genre des
milliers d'euros par mois avec ça
certains qui ont même dépassé la dizaine
de milliers d'euros - à titre de
comparaison gta beaucoup moins genre 300
balles par mois mais ça on va en parler
plus tard pourquoi je parle de type est
aujourd'hui va tout simplement parce que
il y a quelques jours il ya eu un
complément d enquête et michaël goldman
donc le boss de type i a dit ça en fait
j'assume tout ce qu'il ya sur ce site
des du plus antisémite au moins
antisémites et voilà et duplus
complotistes au moins complotistes
j'assume tout ce qu'il ya sur ce site
parce que tant que ces gens là n'ont pas
été condamnés par la justice pour ceux
qui le disent je ne vois aucune raison
valable et morale de les enlever du site
et je le redis même que nous on fera en
sorte de les défendre sur le site voilà
en gros il y avait quelques comptes tipi
qui pourrait être problématique et la
journaliste a posé la question à tipi
est ce que vous cautionnez le fait de
voilà d'héberger ses comptes la sur
votre plateau à ces propos ils ont été
d'une certaine façon sortis de leur
contexte en si je vais être totalement
juste et pour ça je vais lire quelques
extraits du communiqué de presse de
tipis depuis la création type idée qu un
créateur reçoit ses premiers tips sa
page doit être validé par nos chefs de
projets et pour ce faire il faut
notamment que le créateur ne tiennent
aucun propos illégale sur sa page ou
dans les contenus qui fait financer
l'antisémitisme la xénophobie ou les
dérives sectaires en font évidemment
partie ainsi nous excluons chaque année
des dizaines de créateurs lorsque
journalistes nous ont exposés ces trois
projets nous avons répondu que du plus
antisémite au moins antisémites du plu
complotistes au moins complotistes nous
assumons tout ce qui est sur le site
nous comprenons tout à fait que cette
phrase sortie de son contexte aient pu
choquer ou créer un doute sur nos
valeurs est ce que nous sommes
ce que nous voulions dire c'est que
puisque nous avons vérifié qu'ils ne
tiennent aucun propos xénophobes illégal
ou sectaire au regard du droit
l'antisémitisme ou le complotisme que
nous pourrions leur poser reposerait sur
notre perception subjective de leurs
discours que les créateurs eux-mêmes
pourrait nier et sur laquelle nous nous
sentons incapable ni même légitime de
trancher alors suite à ça et lui des
créateurs et des créatrices qui ont
quitté la plateforme il y en a qui sur
leur page 6 pi ont dit ok en fait ne
donnait pas sûr tipi données sur your
type une autre plateforme qui
apparemment est plus éthiques mais voilà
les choses sont allées très vite et moi
j'ai trouvé que cette discussion là
l'apprend fois que je les ai entendus et
quand j'en ai parlé autour de moi m'a
choqué que cette discussion n'était pas
évidente en fait bon évidemment je parle
pas de l'antisémitisme du racisme de la
xénophobie du sexisme qui tombent sous
le coup de la loi qui sont condamnables
et qui n'ont absolument pas leur place
sur tipi c'est évident pour moi ici
c'est pas le sujet non moi la partie qui
me questionnent vraiment c'est le
complotisme vous le savez j'ai
mangé les faits qui news me rendre ouf
et encore plus quand ça touche à la
crise sanitaire par exemple le
documentaire hold up s'est fait financer
en partie sur tipi à lévis d'abord un
financement sur ulule et ensuite une
fois qu'il est sorti que c'est à railler
une page sur tipi pour récolter d'autres
bon ça ça me pose problème pour autant
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas laisser ces
discours exister sous couvert en fête de
la liberté d'expression c'est un peu ce
que sous-entend un moment jonas marie
mecs très cool au demeurant chef de
projet chez tipi on écoute on voudrait
pas tranché le vrai du faux le juste de
l'injuste le bond du mal
le bien du mal pardon sur des domaines
aussi divers que l'histoire la médecine
la politique etc etc et quelques temps
j'ai vu et d'ailleurs avec vous sur
twitch on l'a regardé ensemble un
documentaire qui s'appelle de sochaux
dilemma le documentaire il en deux
parties en français c'est derrière nos
écrans de fumée le documentaire landes
deux parties la première partie c'est
sur l'addiction au téléphone et la
seconde partie c'est sur l'effet bulle
ou bien le concept de bulles de filtres
en tout cas je vous en ai déjà parlé il
ya un an en vous disant qu'il fallait
que se développe le concept leur est
venue en gros c'est simple aucun de nous
n'a le même internet même des endroits
qui semble comme un genre par exemple
google et là on n'a pas les mêmes
résultats de recherche google même si on
tape la même chose parce que ça se fait
en fonction de goût on est en fonction
de nos recherches précédentes en
fonction de plein de paramètres c'est
évidemment flagrant sur les réseaux
sociaux parce que bah on n'a pas le même
feed twitter instagram en fonction des
gens qu'on suit d'ailleurs petite
parenthèse c'est pour ça que l'ong les
tendances sur youtube il fait autant
parler c'est parce qu'en fait c'est
extrêmement rare d'avoir un endroit sur
internet où on voit tous la même chose
et à tendance youtube il ya peut-être
les tendances twitter en fait n'y a pas
énormément d'endroits sur internet ou ce
genre de choses arrive et donc du coup
cet effet bul bat parfois avoir
l'impression qu'un truc est hyper
important que tout le monde en parle
mais en fait c'est juste notre
écosystème à nous qui en parle et cet
effet bull il est amplifié par le fait
que généralement on ne suit que des gens
qui pensent comme nous parce qu'en fait
dans notre timeline qu'on voit un truc
avec lequel on n'est pas d'accord ça
nous saoulent donc on voit une fois deux
fois trois fois ou d'un moment on dire
toi je le dois et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'on est hyper surpris les moments
de résultats d'élections parce qu'en
fait c'est un moment où on sort de notre
bulle on est l'agent mais comment lui il
attendre pour cent de voix
comment c'est possible mais en fait tu
peux pas le comprendre parce que tu es
dans ta bulle quoi tu c'est une grosse
surprise pour toi parce que tu es dans
cette bulle là mais le souci de l'été
bull ou des bulles à filtre c'est la
prise d'information quand vous êtes dans
une bulle de plates east c'est à dire
celles et ceux qui pensent que la terre
est plate c'est un vrai truc hein voilà
plus chanceux la plupart d'entre vous le
savent mais si les gens qui découvrent
le phénomène
ça existe et bien si vous êtes dans une
bulle comme ça l'information que vous
recevez elle est fausse et la fecq news
et là c'est grave parce qu'il n'y a pas
de discussion possible entre les
différents points de vue parce qu'il
n'ya pas de socle commun de vérité un
débat fertile c'est en gros un socle
commun de vérité sur lequel on va avoir
des visions avec des arguments qui
s'opposent et parfois on va aussi
débattre de ce que c'est ce socle commun
de vérité et donc on va la fim et cette
vérité mais avec certains discours qu'on
entend aujourd'hui on est tellement dans
des espaces genre radicalement opposées
ou qui n'ont qui n'ont rien à voir entre
eux qu'il n'y a pas de socle possible
qui a pas de socle commun possible ça se
rejoint pas quoi sont joints typiquement
la terre est un globe la terre est plate
c'est quoi ton socle commun c'est que la
terre elle existe super le problème avec
tipis et hold up pour moi c'est un
problème beaucoup plus large sur lequel
on porte pas assez notre attention c est
ce qu il faut laisser les faits qui nous
au nom de la liberté d'expression c'est
une question très délicate et pendant
longtemps je pense que jusque l'année
dernière ma réponse a été claire c'était
oui oui il faut laisser la liberté
d'expression c'est le plus important
l'idée c'était que y avait comme un
marché libre des idées et que en les
laissant s'affronter les bonnes idées
les mauvaises idées eh bien les bonnes
idées triompherait notamment voir la
vérité triomphe ray par exemple c'est
julien sur le baptiste et bien ça veut
dire que
les platines à force d'être confronté à
un discours scientifiques qui prouvent
que la terre est sous forme de club et
par elle finira par changer d'avis cette
logique c'est la même que celle du
philosophe anglais john stuart mill qui
dit dans de la liberté que la
connaissance émane d'une perception plus
clair et une impression plus vivante de
la vérité produite par sa collision avec
l'erreur c'était ma conviction profonde
il faut le dire c'est une vision assez
optimiste des choses parce qu'on part du
principe que la vérité triomphe sur le
mensonge le problème c'est qu'un plat
tistes par exemple si vous lui montrez
point par point pourquoi la terre n'est
pas plate
et pourquoi la terre est un globe
eh bien il restera persuadé que la terre
est plate et un documentaire 9 lits sur
le sujet c'est assez fou parce qu'il ya
un moment où on fait les plates east
font une expérience pour essayer de
prouver que la terre est plate
sauf que le résultat de cette expérience
c'est que la terre est justement
série voit que c'est un globe eh ben ils
n'acceptent pas le résultat l'expérience
il dit non mais en fait c'est parce
qu'il ya eu 6 et ça en fait ils veulent
tellement chercher quelque chose qui
vont ajuster l'expérience changer si
changer ça machin jusqu'à se trouver un
résultat qui leur convient c'est un
problème et c'est pas le seul il peut y
avoir des dérives à la philosophe
américaine hannah arendt elle en parle
dans les origines du totalitarisme
s concentre sur la propagande ai dit
voilà la propagande c'est un moment on
va modifier la vérité pour manipuler une
population et je crois que c'est quelque
chose dont j'avais conscience mais qui
m'avait moins marqué avant la crise
sanitaire parce que là avec la crise
sanitaire en fait c'est directement des
vies qui sont en jeu à petite parenthèse
les autres sujets sont pas moins graves
c'est juste que c'est moins direct ça va
affaiblir les démocraties ça va créer la
défiance vis-à-vis de l'autorité soit
l'autorité scientifique on importe quel
type d'autorité ex tard accède à la la
crise sanitaire c'est vraiment
directement genre des gens qui vont à
l'hôpital quoi aux etats unis le
discours autour du cou vide il était
très politisé genre beaucoup plus que
chez nous nous quelqu'un qui n'est pas
de masque ou qu'ils voulaient pas se
confiner etc c'est assez difficile de
savoir dans quel bord politique qui se
trouvait
aux états unis
globalement si vous vouliez pas mettre
de masques donc vous voulez pas vous
confiné vous étiez républicain quoi en
gros et s'étaient accentuées par des
médias comme fox news qui était accusée
régulièrement de relayer défectueuse a
carrément une page wiki nous comme le
bras avec tout un tas fait que nous
répertorions et donc si vous connaissez
mal fox news en gros c'est un média
républicain donc non démocrate a
forcément ses discours ils ont eu des
impacts et du coup je me suis posé une
question je suis dit est ce que il est
le plus de morts dus qu'aux vide du côté
des républicains que du côté des
démocrates
et la réponse est oui plein d'études je
vous mets plein d'études etc ce ne sont
pas toujours les bonnes idées qui
triomphe ni les idées vrai et quand je
vois ces mensonges et ces faux discours
qui impacte la vie des gens et qui même
tu certaines personnes bah j'ai du mal à
vouloir les défendre
pour la liberté d'expression en fait ce
n'est pas l'idée que je me fais de
liberté expression et pour moi ce n'est
pas ce à quoi elle doit servir
aujourd'hui quand je vois des
plateformes comme tipi qui permettent à
des documentaires comme hold up de se
financer ça me pose problème ça me pose
quand même et d'ailleurs je vais fermer
mon compte tipi alors ça fait vachement
action revendicatrice dit comme ça mais
en fait ça fait pas mal de temps que je
me pose la question c'est une décision
qui est très facile pour moi parce que
moi en fait très vite vu que tipi n'a
pas pris j'ai changé mon business model
et je me suis beaucoup plus tournée vers
les vidéos sponsorisées et c'est donc de
toutes façons je me posais la question
de le faire parce que baj ils ferment
jamais besoin est là j'en ai moins
besoin il ya d'autres manières de me
soutenir par exemple quand on a sorti
des collections et vous étiez vous
rendez vous et c'est de la balle ou bien
avec les seuls sur twitter par exemple
donc voilà j'aurais pu le faire passer
pour une action gens revendiquent à très
charmant c'est pas s et éthiques je me
barre c'est pas le cas
par contre si un jour je relance un
projet de crowdfunding
que ce soit sur n'importe quelle
plateforme et ben j'espère que vous
serez au rendez vous parce que ça voudra
dire que j'en aurais vraiment besoin et
que ce serait un truc important pour moi
et au passage humainement j'ai toujours
eu de très bonnes relations avec les
gens qui travaillent chez tipi voilà
donc vous regarderez sûrement cette
vidéo je vous salue maintenant quelques
parfois de logique aussi si je fermais
mon compte tipi pour mes convictions bah
il faudrait aussi que je ferme mes
contes jeux pas potentiellement youtube
facebook twitter aujourd'hui il faut
comprendre que toutes ces plateformes
est se nourrissent du temps que l'on
passe à naviguer sur elle et ses
contenus que je condamne la depuis le
début de la vidéo ces déconvenues qui
sont très engageant qui entraîne un gros
nombre de like et ses acquis qui
entraîne des émotions fortes donc c'est
le genre de contenu qui se fait
naturellement poussé par les alouettes
alors moi la plateforme que je connais
le mieux c'est youtube et je m'étais
posé la question à un moment je passe
vous souvenez j'avais fait une vidéo où
je teste l'algorithme youtube où on part
de vidéos complotistes on regarde où est
ce qu'on arrive on parle de vidéos qui
sont pas complotisme et informative en
guerre où est ce qu'on arrive et ceara
et j'ai même pu interviewer quelqu'un de
chez youtube qui travaillent sur
l'algorithme voilà c'était hyper
intéressant pour mahut le travail
beaucoup à essayer d'endiguer ce genre
de problème pour être très honnête c'est
un travail que je vois beaucoup moins
sur twitter par exemple j'ai vu
énormément de contenus anti vax passé
sur la plateforme est pour moi elle a
une responsabilité elle a une
responsabilité
dans les gens qui font des overdoses
d'ivermectine ou ou de chloroquine comme
il ya pu y en avoir un moment parce que
comme je vous le disais c'est con il
faut ils sont beaucoup plus viraux que
des contenus vrai et ça ça a été prouvé
d'ailleurs mon jeu cette vidéo il ya
nicki minaj qui a fait un tweet pour
dire que le pote de son cousin après une
injection du vaccin a eu les testicules
qui ont gonflé que depuis les stériles
et twitter donc le tweet a pris des
proportions énormes et twitter ne veut
pas supprimer tweet parce qu'ils disent
que ça ne rendent pas en contradiction
avec leur guide line voilà alors si vous
êtes inquiet par rapport à ça sachez que
on a fait une expérience sur 45 hommes
en bonne santé et on a analysé leur
sperme avant et après le vaccin et tout
va bien je rappelle aussi qu on ait plus
de 2 milliards je crois ou deux
milliards et demi j'en sais je sais même
pas où est ce qu'on est ce qu on en est
quand j'avais fait ma vidéo avant l'été
on était à plus de 2 milliards en tout
cas de vacciner donc voilà je préfère le
préciser au cas où il ya des
réfractaires et tout un show je parle de
nicki minaj il faut aussi que je donne
le gouvernement est d'ailleurs il paraît
même que le vaccin donne à votre sperme
le goût de barbe à papa donc vraiment
n'hésitez plus quoi foncer c'est une
fiction c'est une ville en fête à terme
cette liberté d'expression qu'on veut
défendre coûte que coûte
sauf qu'à nous cause aussi du temps et
on doit adapter notre manière de la
défendre est ce qu'elles signifient à de
nouveaux usages quand il y avait un
nombre limité devant nos excès moins
facile de colporter des informations
qu'elles soient vraies ou fausses elle
n'avait pas le même rôle et la même
place que dans un monde qui est le monde
actuel où n'importe qui peut devenir un
média aujourd'hui ça m'arrive d'avoir
l'impression que défendre coûte que
coûte l'expression
c'est parfois la détruire évidemment que
la limite et c'est délicat parce que ça
pose une autre question
c'est qu'est ce que la vérité comment on
peut être sûr de ce qu'on avance comment
on peut être sûr qu on est du bon côté
c'est quoi le bon côté est ce qu'il y a
un bon côté on en parlera sûrement dans
une prochaine vidéo mais dans cette
vidéo la voilà je voulais vous portez
votre attention sur ce problème là et
vous présenter cette réflexion de nom
défendre la liberté d'expression à tout
prix n'est pas indiscutable petite
anecdote pour finir je passe vous voyez
cette phrase qui est un peu symbole de
la liberté d'expression qui est
je déteste ce que vous écrivez mais je
me battrai pour que vous puissiez
l'écrire et bien celles et ceux qui la
connaissent pense sûrement que c'est
voltaire et ben non en fait il n'a
jamais dit ça c'est evelyne béatrice
crawl voila voila c'est c'est une fille
qui nous met elle tue personne j'espère
que cette vidéo vous aura plu je voulais
sincèrement remercier toutes celles et
ceux qui depuis des années maintenant
m'ont soutenue sur tipi sans aucune
contrepartie qui l'ont fait vraiment
parce que ils ont cru en mon projet
parce qu'ils ont voulu soutenir cette
vision en fait cette vision qui me
pousse à poster toutes ces vidéos sur
internet depuis huit ans maintenant ça
me touche énormément voilà je vous le
dis ça me touche énormément
merci beaucoup et je pense que mais a
soutenu un moment où j'en avais bien
besoin et maintenant que j'ai pu tibi
comment on pouvait me soutenir et bien
tout simplement en regardant mes vidéos
en les like an en les partageant suivez
moi aussi sur instagram et twitter parce
que quand je passe vidéo sur youtube au
moins je poste sur ces réseaux là comme
ça vous pensez toujours à moi parce que
internet est cruel car internet oubli
vous êtes internet mais ne soyez pas
cruel on se revoit la semaine prochaine
pour se demander si vous êtes des merdes
je souhaite une excellente rentrée love
peace
ciao